Let's now take a look in more depth at one of the most sophisticated defense
systems on the planet,
the vertebrate immune system,
and we'll begin with the innate immune response,
which is rapid in general.
There are some design issues that are involved in thinking about how evolution
has constructed the immune system.
One of its functions is to protect the organism against pathogens.
Another equally important is to manage relationships with commensal Microbiota.
Yeah.
The problems are that pathogens can reinfect.
They are diverse and they can evolve and they're made from the same stuff that
we are.
Okay.
The solutions are to remember past infections,
to develop a system that can respond flexibly to pathogens with characteristics
that have never been seen before,
and to figure out how to write,
recognize self and not destroy self.
Okay,
so these are large benefits,
but of course they can bring with them then large costs.
Okay.
The innate immune system is one that's found in all animals.
It has several functionally autonomous defense modules.
These evolve to deal with different classes of pathogens.
The epithelial barriers.
Mucosa and skin are ancient phagocytes and their antimicrobial defenses such as
lysozymes,
reactive oxygen species and nitrous oxide are also ancient.
The complement system and the acute phase proteins are proteins found in the
blood that can coat pathogens and inactivate them.
Antiviral defenses include natural killer cells and k cells and type one
interferons.
These are evolved a bit more recently.
Yeah.
Mast cells,
eosinophils and basophils are cells that defend us against parasites like worms.
Okay.
The macrophages and the neutrophils ourselves that eat that phagocytose
microbial cells and they deliver them.
Then to the lysosomes for digestion.
Lysosomes are organelles in inside the macrophages and neutrophils,
the detection of a viral infection.
Then he listens production of type one interferons and they induce about 200
proteins that have antiviral activities.
The detection of a multicellular parasite,
like a worm,
triggers deployment of mass cells and basophils.
They produce histamine to increase blood flow to the tissues of,
they produce eosinophils that fight parasites with reactive oxygen species,
cytokines,
enzymes and mucus in the Mucosal epithelium to expel the parasites.
So this is a complex and fairly rapid reaction,
which is part of the innate immune system.
Yeah.
The complement system is about 20 blood proteins that complement the functions
of antibodies and phagocytes.
Okay.
Compliment.
The term compliment refers to the whole set is activated by the detection of a
component of a microbial cell wall.
It can directly lice some microbes and others it coats,
this is called opsonization marking them for phagocyte destruction,
so it's kind of like the forester going through the forest and putting a yellow
flag on a tree that should be cut down.
Complement proteins are produced by the liver in response to signals of
inflammation,
so the liver is a very important immune Oregon.
The innate immune system relies on recognizing patterns and it uses reset
receptors to do that.
It has pattern recognition receptors like the toll like receptors that sense
microbial infection.
These receptors detect conserved structures that are unique to microorganisms
and that are essential to their function.
Activating these receptors produces and immediate inflammatory and antimicrobial
response.
That's mediated by cytokines by particular cytokines,
Interleukin one,
interleukin six [inaudible] and by tumor necrosis factor,
TNF,
TNF Alpha tumor necrosis factor alpha.
These are signaling molecules that talk between cells.
That's why they're called cytokines.
Yeah.
These coordinate a complex response that involves liver or bone marrow.
The hypothalamus fat and muscle.
So although the immediate language is molecular and cellular,
the response being coordinated as one that covers the whole body and major organ
systems,
they activate activate dendritic cells,
which are sentinels,
that are posted in most tissues to detect and digest pathogens and dendritic
cells will then present their antigens to t cells and that will initiate the
adaptive immune response.
So the cytokines that are released by phagocytes activate the acute response.
Yeah.
They are proteins that are made by one set of cells.
The defect of the behavior of other cells and the cytokines Ion Ila six and new
tumor necrosis factor Alpha will be activating cells in liver,
bone marrow,
hypothalamus,
fat muscle and engine dendritic cells in liver.
Liver will produce acute phase proteins and activate compliment bone marrow will
mobilize neutrophils and produce sites that will then produce Vegas sites and
lead to phagocytosis.
The hypothalamus will increase body temperature,
so this is fever fat and muscle cells are going to be mobilizing protein and
energy to allow increased body temperature.
This will lead to decreased viral and bacterial replication,
increased antigen processing,
and increased specific immune response.
So this raised temperature is part of a coordinated response to infection.
The dendritic cells migrate to lymph nodes and mature where they then present
antigens to t cells and initiate the adaptive immune response.
Okay,
so to summarize,
the innate immune system is a generalized and ancient immune system based on
molecular recognition patterns that are shared by broad classes of pathogens.
Is it a virus?
Is it a bacterium?
Is that a fungus or is it a warm,
yeah,
this system reacts quickly.
Some of its components are actually continuously active.
Compliment,
for example,
it activates the adaptive immune system and it instructs it about which kind of
defense to produce.